that men on that man what else did they
what else did they announce Justice
League dark witch wait so that's going
to be a feature no cuz they even
announce a director just a title just a
title
first big ammo right he what it was but
not no longer no he's never doing it no
really why I think that he wanted to
make an actual movie haha oh you've been
Batgirl which we knew about so it didn't
just Batgirl just anger they give it a
title or anything this is this flat out
back in time and they bring out anybody
like Whedon with air and now Whedon
still in London shooting a reshooting so
Justice League is here at the [ __ ] he
shooting you said never hound go where's
everybody this is a dark sky he shooting
ring of trash over London Green Lantern
Corps they've told us about that may
tell us about that you know it's
exciting though in the Justice League
trailer which is [ __ ] eye candy galore
ensure they reference yeah Lance
spoilers don't [ __ ] it you're spoiled
they reference lanterns at one point
they're light you hear the voice of what
I'm assuming is Steppenwolf going this
planet or whatever this world has no
Kryptonians no lanterns and I got
[ __ ] so excited my holy [ __ ] they're
finally talking about lanterns without
Ryan Reynolds involved this is gonna be
[ __ ] amazing what do you think it's
going to be well I think they talk a lot
about it being like the gut buddy cop
show where well do you think we'll get a
taste in justice league if they were
smart they would you know what I'm
saying Lance there's a land of it the
greenlighter [ __ ] the ring pulling up
they just held his hand like just do
that that's [ __ ] yeah you do the the
death of a Ventura right and then
[ __ ] the ring falling on you then you
don't even have to cast it you just put
the ring on somebody's hand and then
credits and in fact credits have already
happened let's be honest this is after
the [ __ ] credits you that's genius
though sometimes they get sad because
we're not in charge
I get so wrapped up I'm like let's do
that and I'm like we have no power man
the flash flash point so they're saying
that they're doing a flash and they're
given a subtitles last point which it's
not like we already saw that on a TV
show that lots of people watch every
week look I love that TV show and I've
worked on that TV show but Seafarer
thank you
but to be fair they they you know they
did a variation of that story throughout
all of last season but if you were like
if you're telling me we're going to do
Geoff Johns flashpoint we're going to do
the flash point that you watch the DC
animated movie up it's just going to
have real people in it this time then
I'm definitely I'm on board I think was
worth doing yeah that's a [ __ ]
beautiful story man it really is vainly
well done and there are a lot of moments
that they couldn't replicate possibly in
the flash TV show like [ __ ] think
about flashpoint you got all that
beautiful Thomas Wayne stuff if you've
never followed the story Barry Allen
makes everything right saves mom's life
and makes everything right and the
trickle-down effect the butterfly effect
destroys the DC Universe in ways that at
first are minor and then ways major and
at one point Barry meets the Batman from
this timeline but it's not Bruce Wayne
it's Thomas Wayne his father the boy the
boy is killed in the alleyway and the
father lives to grow up to become an
Avenger and he's a [ __ ] drinker and
he curses and [ __ ] like that and if you
follow that storyline deeper into the
comics the mother became the Joker it
was pretty [ __ ] genius and stuff I
know right doesn't make you want to read
it right now you're not going to see
that in a movie theater minimum five ten
years do yourself a favor go pick up
those books and read them the
old-fashioned way
so if they do that if they're doing
flashpoint where and you know the DC
Universe they do whatever the [ __ ] they
want on the big screen that you know
they're going to do that variation of
Batman so it's definitely worth pursuing
Plus like I love Tom Cavanagh but you
I'll never get enough [ __ ] professor
zoom I'll never get enough backwards
flash eobard thawne
so I'm ready to see that on the big
screen here's what I would love I would
love if Ben Affleck steps away from the
Batman but plays Thomas Wayne yes [ __ ]
[ __ ] but let's make your movie again man
a good idea why don't they have these
meetings that [ __ ] Warner Brothers
and [ __ ] where there it seems like they
have meetings with alike you think
everyone will be unhappy like yeah all
right let's we're done maybe not that
Ben
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]